and this mission are possible we have a  great cast a team is fantastic an hour  ago Kremlin president initiated ghost  Protocol the IMF has been disavowed  what's different about this mission is  that you have a team that's never worked  together before the four of us are all  that remains of the IMF a safe house no  support everybody sort of has unseen  obstacles that we have to overcome how  did the Russians find out it's a setup  they're cast together and cut off it's  them out on their own it's more of a row  Mission Impossible and they are experts  in their individual areas Benji give me  an elevator it's the four of us together  and each one is a very unique piece and  creates this wonderful dynamic of the  team and it's not as if any missions  gonna be rougher than the last one is it  is it this chain is hot it's not a fire  you